this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah well thanks everybody for coming to
week two of our golf symposium webinar
series in conjunction with the GSA and
why that's so suzanne miss has been
instrumental in helping us organize this
today we've got dr. Doug soldat from the
University of wisconsin-madison we're
gonna talk today about optimizing
nitrogen so before we do that we'll just
thank our sponsors really quick people
who are helping us put this together so
the platinum sponsor is Andre and Sun
first turf and ornamental grassland
perils we've got gold sponsors Finch
turf BASF pump irrigation technologies
and MTE and then our silver sponsors
here to Syngenta Ewing nutrient
solutions turf and soil dry checked and
weaver golf turf solutions so the next
order of business
GSA education points so again if you can
get to this screen or just submit your
points section and then on the screen
now for our live viewers you'll see an
approval code here and don't worry about
dropping this down real quick I'll throw
this in the chat box too so you'll have
that to enter in after and then for
anybody arriving late I'll throw that
again in the chat box
later on so first we'll have a quick
presentation from Frankie Frank grass
he's gonna give us a quick update on the
growing season here in the Northeast and
then we'll get right to Doug and talking
about optimizing nitrogen how about this
guy and some golf superintendent posted
this picture and again I was scour and I
couldn't remember where I grabbed it
from but he was the spitting image of
his old man and so we're happy to have
you for week six here I'm not going to
spend a lot of time doing this because I
want to hear what Doug has to say to
shout out to all the crews out there
plant food supporting them with masks
learning to work safe I'd like to see a
little more separation among you guys
actually but we are really hoping for
your safety while you're out there doing
the work
you know you look for things all the
time and how do I want to talk about
what we're going through and teaching
about it without being distracting and
just to remind everybody you know the
ngf has got a section now that they've
devoted to this around kovat and they're
starting to measure you know it's a
consumer it's the business of golf right
and how much your people issue for this
and how anxious are they and for those
of us in the in the i-95 corridor here
you would say they're stitching to the
point of starting to bleed the anxiety
is pretty high and the itch meter is
pretty high as well so you know
obviously our golfers want to get back
but when you think about our golfers you
have to understand something a lot of
the people who we serve the most you
know ninety percent of the rounds are
played by these core golfers who play at
least eight rounds I mean I know a lot
of people play six and seven or eight so
core golfers it's they ready to get
playing and so how are we open pretty
wide open across the United States 45
states and Pennsylvania I think just
said they were opening yesterday you
look in the Northeast and we have by far
the predominance of closed orders at
least as of the 26 some of these things
can change pretty dramatically a
colleague of ours so you used to work at
the University of Minnesota started a
company called greener golf com greener
golf and Parker Anderson and Parker Cone
are involved with this and you know this
is the beginning of how we as an
industry begin to move through this
situation you know this is a business
that we have to run and or at least are
able to run we want to run it safely and
it's very much an experience right I
mean obviously this whole thing is
dampening the sort of experience to a
certain extent but how do we help our
golfers make their way through this
process and you know this may not
necessarily involve golf course
superintendents I personally think in
some ways it should obviously because
they're spending a lot of time on the
golf course and and the Parkers and
greener golf have put together this road
map you
find it on their website there's cards
there's information I contributed to
some some course conditioning things
that they put on there if you're not
open if you are open and so things
change rapidly again just suggestions
for the way to start to operate safely
as we begin to approach this the phased
approach to opening and of course New
York State you know now Cuomo is talking
about us are reopening so obviously
these are the kinds of things we have to
keep in our mind and obviously part of
that is keeping our crew safe so you
know you just can't help if you know
when you're sitting around looking for
things how many golf superintendents are
you know doing some of these sorts of
things big shout out to the golf
superintendents with their kids at the
properties and of course a dog nearby so
this is the new normal right five
summers with five cards and what does
that mean for us well from a growth
perspective let's start to talk about
growing grass this is what we looked at
like about three weeks ago in the soil
about three weeks ago it looked like we
were starting to creep into the low to
mid 50s in the New York metropolitan
area still fairly cool much to the north
well here we are three weeks later and
we've barely advanced much in this soil
temperature regime right so look at how
far behind we are now in some cases
three weeks throughout much of upstate
New York right around normal now the
forecast is calling for you know average
temperatures regularly in the 50s we're
gonna slowly start to emerge from what
looked like as I wrote about in short
cut this week suspended animation of the
growing season now that has resulted as
we've talked about week after week I'm
not sure I've changed this slide at all
in the last four weeks because we've
been struggling in many places to get to
average temperatures across the
Northeast in the 50s and so you know
what did I do
I I looked back at my colleagues one of
his old presentations on nutrients and I
find a slide he puts in there Doggett
Doug you know is so well trained right
coming from Cornell and and and so I
look at
like Oh guess what I've been talking
about growth potential and it really
doesn't relate to the actual growth that
sometimes measured and I'm sure Doug is
going to address that as we talk about
this moving forward and I can't help but
think he's also gonna talk about his
mentor an early mentor of mine when kuso
who talks a lot about it talked a lot
about in his early career about how
responsive turfgrasses are to nitrogen
now why is this all really important and
pertinent well remember what we said the
new normal was and what this is going to
result in and so I'm sure how we're
managing our nutrients particularly
nitrogen with this kind of traffic you
know this could even mean you know lower
rounds but more traffic one wouldn't
think it and so with that Doug and Carl
iets all I have to to say today in my
introduction and just see if there's any
questions on anything I talked about and
if not Doug I'll pass it right off to
you and and see if I set you up on the
tee okay with that commentary I've been
barking about growth potential and then
I'm fishing around yeah what is Doug
said about this in a facet oh well guess
what it doesn't seem to correlate and I
know there's a story behind that that
you're probably going to tell us a
little bit about today
yeah perfect couldn't set me up better
as I okay I'll go into screen share here
and see it cool and look what I found
okay there it is ribbon cutting here in
1992 so all right yeah no we we've been
doing a lot of work on on growth and in
the the reason I care so much about
growth and Frank and I talked about this
when I was a student at Cornell is like
it's the thin it matters but nobody
measures it right wing coup so the guy I
worked for I was collecting clippings
all the time I thought that was normal
and then when I get out and start
reading what other people are doing not
too many people collect clippings they
just you know give it a quality rating
and it's like you know we're not trying
to maximize yield but it doesn't mean it
doesn't matter
you know and so you know I think Michael
Woods in his book short grammar green
keeping says it really nice like the
goal of green keeping is to grow grass
at the slowest rate possible you know so
you got to have a some growth to recover
from the damage but in general you just
want to have the slowest growth rate
possible so why don't you measure that
you know in in in the reason I haven't
been promoting measuring it until this
late in my career here 14 years later is
because it's super hard and I and I
didn't I didn't see the the correlation
between the clipping volume and the
clipping mass so we measure clipping
mass which takes a lot of Labor but
volume is a really good approximation of
it so with that kind of that advance in
our understanding I'm gonna show you
ways that you can use that to to
optimize your nitrogen okay so I got to
start out with this presentation here
the liebig's law of the minimum it's the
thing we teach in our introductory soils
class soil fertility turf grass
fertility you know take a class the
university without hearing about this
law and you know it's not perfect that
can come up with second poke holes in
this thing but it's pretty darn good and
in this case we're looking at a barrel
that the the we're in wisconsin so the
amount of beer in this barrel is limited
by the shortest state here okay and in
in this case it's it's phosphorus so you
you're not gonna get any more beer in
this barrel unless you add phosphorus
and increase the length of that stave at
which point you're gonna become limited
by the next most limiting thing which is
nitrogen so Liebig this justice fondly
lee big fellow figured this out you know
in the 1800s and it's it's a pretty
right okay and so that the reason that
I'll roll my eyes when I see these tank
mixes going out with 17 different
nutrients in them is because really the
grass only needs one of those things at
any given time you're not going to be
with very very rare circumstances are
you going to be limited by more than one
nutrients at the same time and in our
case we're be almost all the time so
sure I'm gonna sit in the next slide I'm
gonna show you a picture of what a looks
like but also but most superintendents
are sitting here at B where your grass
growth rate is is being controlled by
nitrogen now right now it's probably
being controlled by other things that
aren't nutrients like heat Frank you
know Frank was just showing us the the
growing degree days so we can need more
heat to get that situation rectified so
here's a here's situation a this grass
growth is limited by phosphorus and put
all the nitrogen all the calcium in the
world all the potassium down on this and
it's not gonna make this grass grow it's
limited by phosphorus add phosphorus
it's gonna grow like crazy so nitrogen
won't make this grow but phosphorus on
the other hand is not going to make this
one grow this doesn't have a phosphorus
deficiency it is absolutely limited by
nitrogen so liebig's law the minimum is
a really good place to start
you care about grass growth rate you
know the the color and the quality and
the performance and the disease all that
matters but mostly the the thing that
matters is the growth rate you get the
growth rate right and all that other
stuff will follow so Frank showed a
prettier version of this slide that my
predecessor wink who so developed and
this this is Kentucky bluegrass but look
at the amount of clippings he's getting
in yeah related to the nitrate so he
didn't see the clipping production
starts up to pull back and so he was
putting down a pound a week of nitrogen
of course we're down here in the zero to
four zero to five range so the grass is
almost always starved for nitrogen and
so that's the that's the case we're at
nitrogen controls growth okay so if you
measure your growth you're basically
measuring your nitrogen and so that's
what I'm gonna walk you through now so
the other thing you've got to keep in
mind is nitrogen lives in the soil
probably half or more the nitrogen that
you get in your plant is coming from
your soil and your fertilizer program is
just supplementing the rest of it and
it's usually less than half so it lives
in these complex forms and or basically
organic matter
99% of the nitrogen the soils in organic
matter and microbial so the the
availability is difficult to predict
because it's governed by how those might
what you know when the microbes are
working which is usually when
temperatures are warm and and moisture
conditions are good but the reason it's
so tightly linked to growth is because
of this molecule here this grey blue and
red blob this is a protein called
Rubisco and Rubisco nitrogen is a big
component of proteins proteins are built
out of amino acids and a mean is the
that's the kind of a word that signifies
nitrogen so anytime get a protein it's
loaded with nitrogen and with the plant
this this protein grabs carbon dioxide
from the air and and transforms it into
sugar and the more nitrogen you add the
more Rubisco the plant makes which is
the more sugar the plant can make and
the more the plant can grow so you're
literally just when you're adding
nitrogen you're you're giving the plant
more sugar so it's a perfect analogy for
plant food you're feeding the plant with
nitrogen so another slide from from dr.
Koo so here he was doing a fertilizer
trial order to local golf course in
Madison you you see different rates
different timings different sources you
get these different colors these are all
nitrogen deficient meaning more nitrogen
is gonna make them all more green but
really you know how do you pick do you
pick on color do you pick on growth rate
what's the right what's the right choice
so for a long time we say oh it's it's
an art it's an art form but you know it
just like soil water our job is to make
it less of an art form and so I think
we're getting there with the ability to
measure and track and record growth rate
rather than kind of the subjective feel
for things
okay so nitrogen drives growth in almost
all situations your jobs to find that
ideal growth rate and achieve it using
nitrogen and plant growth regulators I
think in this webinar series for the
last several weeks now we've been
talking about thinking about growth
because of CO vid like what what why are
you putting down now
and Premo at the same time right I can
think of reasons that might make sense
but I can think of a lot of reasons
where you're you're just working against
yourself are you trying to reduce growth
you're trying to increase it those two
things do opposite things but our growth
is also affected by all this different
stuff the weather is huge as you all
know soil properties make a big
difference the soil moisture matters
traffic and where and there's probably
others on this list so growth is
affected by all kinds of different
things you just got a couple tools that
you can use to push it in one direction
or the other so you want to make sure
that you understand where the growth is
at naturally and how to and where what
you should be doing to bump it back a
couple years ago we did a traffic
evaluation on some some lawn type
grasses and I you know looking at which
which of these you know tall fescue fine
fescue a couple different Kentucky
bluegrass is performed best under
traffic or no traffic and one of the
things we always do is collect clippings
and so this is the average clippings
produced per month so the scale goes
from 0 to 100 for these five different
grasses that we tested and notice the
you know this isn't the main point here
but the more frequently you mow the less
clipping yield you get so the blue bars
are the yields when we mowed every week
and then you can see the the yield
shoots up when you mow every two weeks
or every pair every month and that's
because you're scalping and it produces
a hormonal response so follow that
one-third rule you're gonna get less
clippings but this is the exact same
scale just this is no traffic and that's
with traffic no traffic with traffic so
let's look at a couple blue grasses HGT
and turf blue they look like they yield
about the same under under no traffic
but when we go to traffic you can see
the HGT is basically double so that
looks like a more traffic tolerant blue
grass to me but the goal here is you
know we want to we want to achieve
probably some uniform growth rate and
maybe that let's say it's 50 so maybe
HGT here is hitting good growth under no
traffic we don't want to add nitrogen to
this situation but we start to throw
traffic on it and our growth drops down
to what 20
five we're gonna have to increase our
nitrogen rate to get this growth up to
50 where we can you know assuming that
50 is the growth rate that we want right
you got to figure out what your levels
are we'll talk about that in a bit but
that's the whole concept here is that by
monitoring your growth you can figure
out what you need to do to manage that
turf to hit those targets so we've been
doing with my with my PhD student to you
Joe just a phenomenal phenomenal student
she's been doing a lot of hard work
looking at the factors that make
creeping bentgrass greens grow soil
organic matter differences amount of
traffic nitrogen weather and on and on
and on and in using that data to build
growth models so Frank talked about the
pace turf growth model basically uses
temperatures so I use this in my class
it is a useful model because it tells
people that temperature is one of the
main most important factors for turf
grass growth so you may be seen on
Twitter people with these avatars that
kind of show whatever their location is
these are four locations in in
California and the blue is the cool
season growth potential and the red is
the warm season growth potential so you
go down to Riverside California you got
these spring and fall Peaks where your
cool season grasses are real happy
summer hits and growth potential drops
off but the warm season Peaks right you
go up to the Olympic Valley and you get
you're basically just cool season growth
you know warm season growth potential
zero so it's a really really cool
simplistic model that that shows you the
basics of the temperature save on that
limiting factor you know the the
liebig's law of the minimum temperature
matters but when we look at our
clippings of the Oh Jane or this is the
actual amount of clippings that we get
and again you can ignore the unit's 0 to
6 here versus what the pace growth
potential model predicted this is what
the graph looks like so it's pretty ugly
overall if you what's the average
clippings that we get it looks like
about one point two and then what's the
average of the growth potential on this
side one point two so I mean it gets the
annual average pretty good but it's not
going to give you on a day-to-day basis
it's not going to predict your your grow
so I love the superintendents that are
out there using growth potential to
determine their nitrogen requirements
but I think it's a mistake to do that on
a weekly or even monthly basis it's
probably better just to look at it
annually so um we think we can build a
weekly or monthly model I thought I'll
talk to you about that in a second
but basically traffic and nitrogen have
pretty similar impacts on unclipping so
let's say 1.2 which is about our average
is our optimum let's say we want to keep
our clippings around 1.2 for maximum
performance under high traffic we would
need a point four pounds in nitrogen
every other week to get to that level
okay so that's a that's a lot of
nitrogen and the high traffic that we
used in this scenario was way too much
traffic we made a mistake in estimating
the amount of traffic and we ended up
doing that low traffic would be a pretty
high level of traffic for the real world
but if you put point four pounds of
nitrogen down every other week you're
way above that one point two target
you're growing too much grass it looks
like 0.2 pounds every other week is
about right and based on my experience
and knowledge two-tenths of a pound
every other week for a high traffic golf
course in Wisconsin is about right if
you're putting down no nitrogen you're
clipping level is too low now if you're
under no traffic which is my typical
research plots we don't need any
nitrogen to hit those growth targets if
we put down 0.2 0.4 we're growing more
grass than we need to so again why do I
do things like we did we used to do with
growth regulators well it says by every
four weeks or every six to eight weeks
on the label so that's what we're gonna
do we go out every other Monday with our
nitrogen at point two you know I know I
know you don't do that I know that
you're adjusting things on a basis but
you probably should be having a target
to determine whether or not those
adjustments make sense now I said
everything affects growth but nothing
affects growth real strongly so this is
a cheese data on how clippings are
affected by soil moisture content you
got these three blobs she was basically
managing turf at about 10 20 and 30
percent soil moisture and you can see
that yeah the
was growing higher but there's a lot of
variability and there it's not a real
strong relationship
similarly with traffic when we look at
it zero rounds per week versus two
thousand rounds per week I'm sure that
the growth goes down but it's not real
super strong relationship so this is
kind of disappointing because it means
that building a model would be tough but
the good news is artificial intelligence
and machine learning is all the rage
right now and that's what this stuff is
built to do is to take these really
crappy relationships throw them in the
computer and spit out something that
works that that I can't even comprehend
or even explain to you why it works what
the computer figures it out and the the
computer tells us you know we throw in
all the weather data all the nitrogen
management data the rounds per week the
type of root zone it was the numbers of
the day's growth the grass had on it all
that stuff we throw into the computer
and it tells us which ones were the most
important for for making the model that
the computer makes and so these are two
different versions but look at what the
most important stuff is for determining
bentgrass growth relative humidity
maximum of the three previous days
relative humidity averaged over five
days three days average temperature for
day of average temperature relative
humidity previous four days minimum so
the first five things that this model
said was important for for bentgrass
growth were relative humidity and
temperature okay that's the stuff in the
Smith currents dollar spot model
nitrogen doesn't show up till the middle
all right I would have thought that
would have been the top it's the middle
thing it's the sixth thing and ndre
that's a nitrogen factor and the Aerie
nitrogen factor wind ET traffic down
here at the bottom so it matters but not
a ton so weather nitrogen traffic and
over here you got you have a root zone
in here organic matter nitrogen rates a
little bit higher in this one so and
every time the computer runs a model is
it turns out a little bit different but
you can learn something from that so
here's our model this is what the the
computer spits out which is super
impressive to me again our scale goes
from zero
and in clipping zero to six this is our
actual clippings and then this is what
the computer predicted and so when the
computer predicts one we're getting
about one when the computer predicts
four we're getting about four so it
works really really good so we're
excited about that
we haven't it takes a lot of computer
programming to be able to read Lisa so
you can use it so we're not quite there
yet but but it's pretty sweet so we're
hoping people can start managing their
nitrogen using models that that are a
little bit more representative of
reality it is cost of the model we're
making is customizable this is
everything we throw at the computer on
the Left we can take out maybe you don't
measure ndre
or even know what the hell that is which
is fine soil moisture content maybe you
don't want to input that into the model
every day and so then when you take
those two things out you still get
pretty good predictions but it drops
down a bit and then the one on the right
is let's say you just want to hook your
weather station up to this thing because
relative humidity and temperature were
so important still not bad you know you
can see the the points start to spread
and scatter a bit but it's a heck of a
lot better than just using the
temperature that is in the in the pace
turf growth model so we're excited about
this let's let's Frank it looks like you
want to say something or maybe no he's
just frozen up on my screen okay
all right I can hear you
we're car I'll think we're losing them
yeah he said he's got a bad connection
so maybe we'll keep rolling and okay
okay so um nitrogen cycle another thing
oh we teach in in all our introductory
classes and the way we teach this thing
is we let we say hey this is really
complicated and it's really hard to
predict nitrogen by looking at these
different components it turns out for
putting greens though sand-based putting
greens the nitrogen cycle is dead simple
and I'm going to show you so this is
actually a nitrogen cycle diagram I
stole from from crops and soils over at
Cornell as it shows the different the
blue things are nitrogen coming into the
system the red things are nitrogen
leaving the system and the green things
are just where the nitrogen lives okay
so what I'm gonna do now is just kind of
take away all the ways that nitrogen is
lost that don't matter to us so we
interfere about runoff and erosion we
don't get those things we don't care
about denitrification doesn't really
happen in a sand-based green we are
research data and from from years and
years of testing know that leaching is
not that important and then
volatilization just doesn't happen in a
sand-based root zone so we can go click
click click click that means the only
nitrogen loss that you have to think
about is your crop harvest that's your
color clipping removal same thing with
inputs we don't get atmospheric well
atmospheric deposition is really small
and it's constant you can predict it
just by looking on a map but animal
manures and bio solids no biological
fixation by legumes soybeans clover no
plant residues no cuz you're removing it
so we can get rid of all that stuff and
the only input to your system is
commercial fertilizer so you got one
input you got one output your fertilizer
you know how much you put down your crop
harvest you have no idea right so all
you have to do is figure out your crop
harvest to figure out if these two
things are in balance that's what you're
shooting for and then the pools are here
the organic nitrogen is the only pool
that we really care about and if your if
your fertilization if your blue box is
bigger than your red box your organic
matter is going to increase if your
fertilization is lower
than your harvest which is absolutely
possible your organic matter goes down
we care a heck of a lot about soil
organic matter it's something that we
measure it's something that we manage so
this balance between your fertilization
and your crop harvest influences it I
can't think of a better reason for you
to start measuring your crop harvest
okay so another way to say this is
basically your your you want your
nitrogen additions to equal your removal
or loss to keep your organic matter
stable if you screw that up if you add
too much nitrogen you're gonna build
soil organic matter you're gonna have
maybe thatch issues and you can start to
run into leaching problems if you overdo
it if you don't put down enough which is
probably the case that we're probably
closer to this deficit issue than on the
surplus on average you're slowly
depleting your organic matter you're
gonna see a steady decline in turf grass
quality over years or decades and
eventually you're just not going to have
enough organic matter to have a healthy
stand we showed this back with Bill
crows work you know back 10 years ago
now at least where he put down different
rates of primo and different rates in
nitrogen and he kind of measured like I
said I've been collecting clippings for
this purpose for years it's just really
it's just really intense of the way I do
it and we basically found that same
thing hey if you're if you're using
primo to reduce your growth you can back
off on your nitrogen by a pretty decent
amount because clipping removal is the
way that nitrogen gets lost if you're
removing less clippings because your
growth regulators are down you can put
less down and to keep that balance there
so to illustrate this we got visual turf
grass quality is 7.5 we can hit that we
if we don't use primo we need to put
down just under three tenths of a pound
every other week to hit that target but
what we found is if we use primo we're
hitting a turf grass quality rating a
7.5 at 2/10 of a pound and so when you
reduce growth it's the it's basically
doing the same thing as increasing your
nitrogen fertilization so those things
go hand in hand the exact same data just
plotted a different way so now on the on
the why
axis we have the amount of fertilizer
applied - the amount of nitrogen removed
and clippings and like I said your goal
is probably to breakeven to be at around
zero and with primo our break-even point
was at about two tenths of a pound and
without primo is at about three tenths
of a pound so again your your amount of
growth can guide the amount of
fertilization that you that you want to
shoot for all right so photo here from
Michael Woods who's been talking about
clipping volume collection for a long
time and and and largely because he was
aware of people in Japan doing it and
monitoring their growth and finding that
that's a really useful thing to do so I
don't think we have really fine-tuned
the optimum growth rates so you know
knowing exactly what to do with that
number in terms of your you know your
your quality and performance but we
absolutely can tell you how much
nitrogen you're removing and it can
inform your nitrogen program so you know
if you're on Twitter you know people are
doing this and they're loving it this I
love this slide from Chris tradeable
who's you know one of the pioneers of
this doing this and talking about it and
so this slide he made is about what he
says when people say why they don't do
it along with this uh this nice shot
from sue Crawford here so why not I
don't know where to find a bucket okay
it takes too long and this is something
that I now know is is one of the
simplest things you do it takes less
than one minute per green it's easier
than doing soil moisture you don't need
a $1200 meter to do this thing it's not
accurate enough but there's nothing that
doesn't make sense at all because what
you're doing now is even less accurate
than this
so of course it's not perfectly accurate
but it's a heck of a lot better than
looking in the back of the buckets it's
hard to keep track of all the data okay
so I'm gonna address that that's the
first good point we've seen and then
this one I can tell by looking in the
baskets yeah right just like you could
tell what the soil moisture was by
feeling it in your hands right of course
you can of course you can get a feel for
it but your soil moisture meter is
better at telling you when your greens
need to be watered then
you've been feeling around in the
moisture I don't I don't need any
superintendents these days who say I'm
better at it than the moisture meter
right of course you used to do that by
looking in the soil and feeling the soil
but the moisture meter makes you better
this makes you better at than looking in
the baskets in Dave Hicks and Karl skew
mentees have this awesome podcast where
they're talking about how collecting
clipping volume help dial in just them
getting the mower set up right so this
is this is one thing that I think is
worth remembering is that humans are
really bad observers and data always
helps us make better decisions
so why you're in you know Cornell's in
wine country that's where I first got my
experience with tasting notes on wine
and you know red wines have these things
like you know raspberry and you know
tobacco and wood and things like that
and the white wines are floral and honey
and all that right so they gave the
exact same white wine to a bunch of wine
drinkers and they to one of them they
added the red dye completely tasteless
completely odorless just made the wine
red and then they ask that person to
tell them you know give us your tasting
notes when the wine was red they used
descriptors associated with red wines
you know that's at the tobacco and the
cherry and the prune and the licorice
and then when they gave him the white
wine they used the white wine words
right and that's what this scatter plot
is showing us is nobody was telling when
that ran when that wine was colored red
nobody was saying hey is a white wine
that's red okay because your eyes tell
you what you what it should taste like
this comic here talking about a nice
ergy will just mill around till he's
asleep and send it back up this
operation is just for placebo this is a
real thing a hundred and eighty patients
who had knee surgery randomly assigned
to three groups the traditional one an
experimental surgery and then a sham
surgery where they just cut the knee
open and then sewed it back up
results are stunning those who had the
actual procedures did no better than
those who had the same surgery but it
wasn't cuz the surgeries didn't work is
because the people that had the sham
surgery got better okay because they
thought they had a knee surgery and so
they came back and said yeah my knee is
better
thanks for cutting it open and sewing it
back up right so are they better I I
guess they are cuz they think they're
better weightlifting study these weight
lifters entered 11 weeks study the first
seven weeks was just a weed out thing so
like you know that the best of the best
here are gonna be entered into the
second phase we're gonna give you
steroids so these people were competing
to remain in the study right they're
trying really hard then the people that
that made the cut
who did the best were given steroids and
look what happened before the pills the
average person was added six pounds to
their squat when they're trying to stay
in the study after they're given the
steroid they added 42 pounds of their
squad same thing with the benchpress ten
pounds before the pills thirty pounds
after the pills guess what there were no
steroids there is sugar pill right so
these people who were trying their
hardest you give them a sugar pill and
they think it's a steroid and magically
they lift more weight okay I mean human
humans are really not logical we're
messed up our brain controls what we do
what we feel how we heal a lot and
you're and you as a turfgrass manager
are absolutely susceptible to that same
stuff the onion does it take on this
right if if the onion does it you know
it's a you know it's real or it's you
know it's part of our society so viagra
announces the real medicine that gave
customers erection was confidence all
along and I promise you that there are
actual data on this you get somebody a
blue pill and you know what's gonna
happen even if it's a blue sugar pill
alright so there's a lot of it so surely
it works and it changed your physiology
but a lot of that stuff is in your head
this gray bar in the middle of this the
shaded area is the same color but to me
it looks it looks lighter on the left
and darker on the right but that's
because it's being my brain is telling
me that because it's influenced by
what's surrounding it so when I click
off
the border yeah now I can see it's all
the same color but my brain will not
tell me that that's the same color gray
bar when I'm looking at it here
okay so superintendents golf course
superintendents are the best observers
of all the turf managers I work with
golf course superintendents are the best
but you're you're not you're still not
that good because you're a human right
so the more data you have the better
you're gonna be and how I know that
you're not that good at observing is
because through my conversations with
you on on primo when people tell me yeah
I put this stuff down just shuts it down
shuts that growth down it's um it's
incredible the difference I go from from
baling hay to know clippings in the
bucket and I just know it's not true
because I've been collecting growth from
primo on greens for 14 years and you
can't tell you can't tell by looking you
can barely tell sometimes by doing it
real carefully so this is what primo
treated versus non treated control looks
like this is actual data from 2008 it's
pretty messy there ain't any shutting it
down in here okay sometimes you can see
it on fairways so you know you I can
show you situations where you would see
it with your eyes but on greens no way
okay so the reason you saw it shut down
was because you you put down that
product and you're experiencing a
placebo effect you expected it to be
shut down so this big drop-off here
let's say we made the application here
on in early August August 8th and then
the weather basically shut down the
grass growth for whatever reason cuz
relative humidity and temperature plays
such a big role and you attribute that
to the Primo okay so and there's no
question in your mind that that because
you applied the Primo that huge decrease
in clippings wouldn't have happened
without it okay so this is what research
data gives you the ability to do put out
your test plots you are not immune to
this no matter how good of an observer
you are without data you are you're a
powerless and the oldest and I don't
want to say like I'm on my high horse
here and I'm a great observer and you're
not I'm terrible too I was in I was in
New Jersey given a talk to the aqua
trolls crew a long time ago I was
sleeping in the bed in the hotel room
and I couldn't fall asleep because it
felt too cold and then like as soon as
as soon as you know I was kind of
thinking do I do I get up and change the
temperature just fall asleep and and
quit thinking about it so I decided to
get up middle the night turn the dial up
on the wall went back to sleep
slept like a baby immediately and then I
woke up in the morning in the in that
thermostat had a sign on it that said if
you want to adjust the temperature go
over to the unit under the window
because this thing doesn't work right
and that right there I'm like yeah you
know that placebo effect is so strong if
you spend a whole bunch of money on on a
product it has already worked the second
you pay that invoice because you're
committed to it mentally it already
worked so just don't forget that and in
the solution to all this is is
collecting data our moisture you know
though our moisture probes have changed
the way that we collect and manage our
moisture I used to have to set up my my
studies to have high irrigation
distribution uniformity and now I don't
care about distribution uniformity I
care about having even distribution of
moisture in the soil and so like in this
case here we're doing a wetting agent
study or they tell us in the contract
you're justyou're d you has to be 80
percent meaning the water has to be
applied evenly or we're not gonna give
you the money well when I apply the
water evenly I get a lot of I get a wet
corner and I get a dry corner if I turn
off this head here in the wet corner my
is my distribution uniform he goes down
to 12 percent but I got a whole lot of
uniformity in my soil moisture content
here so you know that the like the data
revolution and moisture has improved
your management so it's time to let the
clipping collection be the next thing
you again same this is the OJ this is
data from three of my putting greens at
the oj in our Center experiencing the
same temperature right so they're all
Bank grass this is the amount of
nitrogen
in the clippings at different points in
the year from these three grants so you
can see they look totally different and
and you might start managing your greens
a little bit differently because you're
noticing that one green is you're
removing a ton of nitrogen from for some
reason it's growing a lot higher rate
and that this other green is really low
for whatever reason so you're gonna
start to pick up on those things and and
you're gonna become a better manager
because you're gonna notice that not
everything is is uniform in the same
just like you don't water all your
greens exactly the same you probably
shouldn't be putting down nitrogen on
all your greens exactly the same okay so
this is the the kind of the revolution
that that makes clipping collection
possible and easy for you is that
basically the dry weight which is what
I've been recording and dr. Kreutzer has
been recording for years laborious Lee
is really well correlated with clipping
volume so you just got to throw it in a
bucket and say how many liters or
gallons or ports are in that bucket are
square here is 0.67 that's pretty darn
good
like I said not perfect but it's good
mica myself oops and Bill Crozier
compared data a couple years ago and
we're like oh crap my numbers are way
different than yours bills with you know
his relationship here was 0.42 I was
point six or Michael was 0.6 I was up
here at point eight turns out this is
just how we compact them so we asked
bill how do you do it I don't compact
them at all I just throw them in the
bucket I mean if you do it that way this
is your relationship I asked my grad
student Chiyo hey how are you getting
those conversions well she's like I put
it in the bucket I compact it until it
doesn't compact anymore so the clippings
don't go down well then if you're doing
it that way you need to use this
conversion and then we asked Micah how
you do it he says well I just give it to
taps you know somewhere in the middle
and that's where as data falls out so
you do have to pay attention to how
you're packing your clippings but the
spreadsheet are gonna show you the
second uses the woods conversion so
throw it in the bucket and give it to
firm taps allow those you know the big
air gaps to settle out but don't spend
all your time compacting and pressing
like we've done but definitely do more
than just throw it in the bucket like
like Bill did for this for this
demonstration
so one of my former students
Alex B's and Crone who's now the
superintendent at at Blue Mountain
Country Club in Wisconsin was the
assistant or one of the assistants at at
Erin Hills and I said Alex do me a favor
collect clippings for me for this year
and tell me what you think and he loved
it and and they're still doing it so he
says it's it's simple basically the
general staff bought into it and they
liked it because you're giving those
staff members a task and you're you're
asking them to contribute to the higher
level stuff so they say things like hey
you you might want to look at number 12
it's the second day in a row we haven't
gotten much so they're paying more
attention they're not just out there
mowing lines they're actually looking at
their data this is the biggest one in my
opinion basically it allows you to do
quality control and your mowers you
could compare why mowers one and three
are getting less than mowers five and
seven so he gives you some feedback to
give to your mechanic if you got a
triplex you can look at the individual
clippings from each of the three reels
and you might realize that even though
they're said exactly the same you're
getting different amounts of clippings
and you can adjust your your mower setup
to get uniform mowing then alex is
talking about you know it's what it's
wonderful to know how that the nitrogen
and the growth regulators were affecting
growth again if you're under your growth
target why are you putting down a growth
regulator if you're way above your
growth target why are you putting down
nitrogen and and so things like that so
again it's simple I encourage you to do
this if you're not this is the word the
worst part about is the data collection
there's a there's a handful of the
people that are doing it now are
comfortable with this and like
Christmases want to Chris Trudeau Baz
old spreadsheets
I think he's updated it since but I'm
showing how he's he's recording ball
roll speed and all kinds of stuff on a
spreadsheet he made himself but I'm
gonna encourage you to use my
spreadsheet if you're not a data person
I'm gonna just go and show you where to
get it
eww turf dot whisk that edu is our is
our turf programs website here and then
we have
a section called tools and right the
first tool is the Wisconsin clipping
tracker template you click on that and
it just downloads an Excel spreadsheet
and this is what this thing looks like
you
hello you gonna open for me today
you
mm-hmm okay I'm gonna give that a second
where's my presentation err so basically
when that when that opens up whenever
it's ready you just enter your clipping
vault you got to tell me how big your
greens are so you got to enter the the
size of your greens and then you just
enter the number of liters you get from
each screen you can do it for one whole
you can do it for all 18 or however many
holes you have and then it'll it'll grow
automatically graph up your clipping
volume in liters per hundred square
meters so you can see where things are
at and then the thing that I like the
most about it is this it tells you how
much nitrogen you've removed so here in
and this is data from from Erin hills
from a few years ago there you can
they're removing two pounds of clippings
in there during their season okay so
that should inform how much nitrogen
they want to put down you want to you
probably want to be around two pounds if
you want to keep your organic matter
steady let's see if I can see if that
thing out but here it is so paid how to
use this step one enter your information
on your thousand square feet of your
areas and we got custom areas if you got
practice putting greens or whatever and
then we have the whole numbers 1 through
18 in this case the volume to weight
conversion that's the thing I was
talking about with how you compact your
clippings and you can adjust it right
now the default set up to the Michael
Woods way and then percent tissue
nitrogen we assume is 4% if you do have
data you can change at the 5
maybe it's 3.8 whatever it is and that's
gonna that's gonna adjust the amount of
nitrogen you remove but it's it set the
4 which is good a good average if you
don't have data you enter your clipping
data here depending on the day and then
you get your clipping volume chart I
don't have any data in here and then
I'll tell your estimated removal and
then this is where all the calculations
happen so just stay away from the
calculations page so it's so easy that
there's no excuse not to do it because
you don't want to do the the data
analysis so you know I've sent this
tracker out to a bunch of people that I
work with here in the Midwest and asked
them some questions about their property
and the average person is getting about
two liters per 100 square meter micah is
now talking about this in milliliters
per square meter
it's just liters per hundred square
meter times 10 so but anyway that that's
about two right and from that the
estimated nitrogen removal is only 1.1
pounds which surprised me I thought they
ought I would see higher numbers in that
but but you know that's what the data
are saying again this is only from about
10 courses in the Upper Midwest the
emerging guidelines from golf course
superintendents who are doing this or
they're saying one liter per thousand or
a hundred square meter is good for
tournament conditions but it's probably
not sustainable
2 liters is a good target for daily
average interesting that that's exactly
how it it turned out for these 10
courses and then when you start to get
into 4 liters per hundred square meter
we're talking excessive now this is
probably a these guidelines are probably
about as useful as me telling you in the
morning you want to have your soil
moisture around 20 to 22 percent and you
know your greens are gonna wilt when
they get down around 9 or 10 percent
okay nobody's gonna drastically disagree
with that but you you might say oh my
number 17 in the morning or my numbers
25 in the morning so these are ballpark
and but when you start to collect your
clippings you're gonna figure out what
you like you know maybe you can survive
down here at one and a half liters per
100 square meter or closer to one for
for a better part of the year for
whatever reason maybe you got to be
above 2 I don't know but it's gonna be
somewhere in that ballpark so wrapping
up here turf grass fertilization is is
gonna it's headed to the liebig's law of
the minimum where soil testing is gonna
stop driving our fertilizer inputs I'm
always I'm bothered by the the data that
that GCS double a found where people
that soil test apply a lot more
treants and people that don't and I
don't think what they're saying is
people that soil tests have a lot worse
turf than people that don't so in your
soil testing you get all those
interpretations that are based on super
conservative targets you end up throwing
down fertilizer chasing targets that
aren't real you know it feels good to
hit targets but it's not a real thing
so stop relying on soil testing
you know it's a whole nother talk for me
but keep it simple focus on your
nitrogen management that's what your
plant needs that's what's driving growth
that's what matters
use use clipping volume to determine
your fertilization not your soil test
report you're gonna figure out your
growth targets we're gonna we're gonna
continue refining them we're gonna build
that model that's gonna if you don't
want to click clippings or you skip it
for a couple weeks for whatever reason
our model will fill in the gaps and
you're gonna start using your nitrogen
in your PG R's more in tandem rather
than you know in opposition rather than
in tandem I should say to hit your
growth targets I know people are already
doing this we don't the turfgrass
sciences community we don't do anything
in a vacuum right all this stuff is
based on conversations with you we're
trying to refine the management that
you're doing by using data so you know
anything I've said today please don't
take offense that I don't think you
don't know this stuff conceptually I'm
just trying to give you the tools and
the background data to use it to use it
better just another really nice slide
here from Chris Trudeau boss showing how
he's thinking about how nitrogen
management's going to change in instead
of I said don't fertilize all 18 greens
the same you can take that another step
fertilis don't even don't even fertilize
putting green number 5 all the same and
so here he's got that split up this is
how you water right you water your
driest spot you rot your entire green to
the amount that the wettest spot needs
and then you start hand watering the
ones that need more right that's that's
the best way to water a green that has a
wide gradient moisture you should
probably be thinking about doing that
for nitrogen - you got this low area in
the back
that doesn't get a lot of traffic
doesn't need a lot of nitrogen you got
this front area here that needs two
times as much nitrogen as that back area
okay so this is prot you should probably
be thinking about your nitrogen
management almost exactly how you think
about your water management in terms of
that you're doing it based on data and
you need different amounts in every way
so I did this up and I did this talk up
in northern Wisconsin last year the year
before and one of the one of the
distributor reps came up to me
afterwards who's he former
superintendent his dad was a
superintendent second generation up in
northern Wisconsin and he said that was
great and he's like you know what though
that that last slide you showed about
the clipping you know how are
fertilizing the greens that's how my dad
would do it in 60s you know we go out
we'd have maps and we'd fertilize these
areas twice so again I know people have
been this isn't like revolutionary stuff
but hopefully it gets you thinking about
how to how to change your management or
to hit growth targets rather than than
just doing things on the on the calendar
okay um Chris Richter invited me to give
this presentation and I'm you know I'm
immensely disappointed we didn't get to
do it in person up in Rochester for the
inaugural event there I was scheduled to
give two talks so that was basically one
of them and then this is one slide on my
second talk and I always you know you
should always be able to sum up a
50-minute presentation in one slide you
never know you need it so here it is
we've been doing a lot of work with iron
I got all kinds of things to say about
iron but iron sulfate six ounces per
thousand every seven days spray volume
doesn't matter but gallon and a half in
this picture it's pretty darn good
dollar spot control so this isn't a
non-treated in 2017 versus that program
on the right here's the same program in
2018 under higher pressure if you start
deviating from this if you go lower than
six ounces if you go less frequently in
seven days it ain't gonna work
so yes dollar spa or iron sulfate can be
an amazing dollar spot control but you
got to put down a lot of it and it's got
to be pretty frequent so we're working
on you know with Paul Coe
and the Smith Kern's dollar spot model
stuff and seeing if we can target
windows where you can go out and and do
this program intensively for four or
five weeks and then you know when dollar
spots not in season you can probably
back off on it a bit but pretty cool
tool here to minimize the use of
fungicides especially on fairways for
cost reasons and maybe for environmental
reasons as well so that's that's my iron
update in a nutshell and guys I think
that's all I have be happy to open it up
for chat in for questions so can you
guys hear me or is my connection not
good we can hear you okay Doug let me
ask about Alex at Blue Mound the fifth
point on that slide said he didn't
fertilize from May to July with nitrogen
using this clipping collection method
can you chat about that for a second you
want to pull that slide back up and and
maybe just chat about that point because
you know that's really ground truing
that's sort of testing out traffic and
otherwise now I don't know what traffic
at Blue Mound is like that's one of the
great beautiful golf courses in
Wisconsin I don't know how busy oh well
this would this was there in Hills data
there's no no no back to Alex's yes
point yeah yeah yeah but I mean that was
relative they're in Hills so this one
yep right so he wants where's Erin Hills
not at Blue Mound right right so he says
you know we went from May to July
without any nitrogen and that's the
longest stretch we've gone let's go look
at his graph here this is the Erin Hills
removal there's two different data sets
he was removing nitrogen even though he
wasn't fertilizing he was removing it
yet why like I said in the beginning
most of your nitrogen comes from your
soil so the soil was giving that grass
enough growth to hit his growth target
where he is saying don't add it that's
how you use it and that's how simple it
is
so I mean literally give give you the
spreadsheet one time and you're making
adjustments like that
now now isn't I mean okay I know from
visiting and the life we've been living
it's been raining for the last couple of
years Doug and so I'm and we
this on our Cornell golf course right
after a rain the lag would result in a
big spike of uncontrolled growth even
under growth regulators so is this is
this about the amount of moisture in
that system as well yeah I think so and
that's what we're seeing with with chi
use data too is that when you're keeping
it as dry as you're keeping it you're
you're you're handcuffed in those soil
microbes they can't break that organic
matter down like they'd like to so when
it gets a spike they're happy right and
so we're seeing that soil moisture plays
a big role in growth and I've seen your
data and and and that's more evidence
and if you look here at these spikes
here in this is the average clipping
volume and the dots are individual days
it's spiky that's why I'm saying like
primo reduces your girl 320 percent your
growth on a day-to-day basis fluctuates
by a factor of five five times right you
can't tell a growth regulator 20% when
things are bouncing around by a factor
of five and it's because of the those
flushes of growth you get from the
rainfall and stuff you know the relative
humidity and things like that
all right listen since you're on this
excel page I want to draw your attention
to the percent nitrogen in the tissue
this is a always this reverberating
question the value of tissue nitrogen
concentration you put it in there as a
factor of how you adjust maybe how much
n you're taking off or finding and that
might be something I know that there are
firms that do this that you send them
your clippings and they'll analyze them
for you on a regular basis can you talk
a little bit about knowing this number
is it important and how much will it
influence the way you wind up
fertilizing yeah
it's not it doesn't fluctuate a lot
which is why clipping volume alone is
good it a good average is four percent
it's certainly not going to be four
percent every time you test so Chris
Trudeau bought a Hazeltine said based on
our average testing we're actually at
four point eight
good use 4.8 but it's not something that
you need to track right along with the
clippings all the time so if you got you
know what the way I like to see tissue
testing is three times a year spring
summer fall keep it simple gives you
your potassium numbers at a time where
it makes sense
take those nitrogen numbers to average
them together and throw them in this box
right here it's gonna be close to four
but you know and that could be when I
said you know I was surprised to see how
low that the nitrogen removal was from
the Midwest superintendence you know by
bumping the clipping the percent tissue
nitrogen to four to five is gonna
increase that 20% and so it could be
it's gonna move your target around a
little bit but it's not gonna change a
lot of stuff okay
how about other questions for Doug Carl
yeah so Greg was asking a question
relating to frequent small amounts of
nitrogen versus maybe two or three times
a year
slow-release can you talk doubt about
how that may change your growth rate and
if that provides more or less
fluctuation yeah I mean on greens this
is all green stuff really you know we
haven't talked much about fairway
fertilization where you might employ a
slow-release fertilizer but I don't use
I wouldn't use slow-release fertilizers
on Green's it doesn't make sense you're
out there too many times you should have
a tighter can I don't care what your
budget is you should have tighter
control over your over your nitrogen
with a soluble source so that's my view
on that you know maybe a few exceptions
for after you put it to bed there solar
this nitrogen is gonna get mowed off
mostly and the liquid slow releases I
don't love so if you're talking fairways
though yeah you know the the target the
growth targets are probably less
critical but you can you can probably
get by with spoon feeding your fairways
too depending on your number
applications urea is super soluble you
can put down a quarter of the pound at
least maybe up to 0.4 pounds at a single
time without burning so you know slow
you got to have a real good reason
to pay for a slow-release fertilizer in
in my mind okay so this is a very
interesting question Doug because as we
confront you know the correction that's
gonna happen in golf one of the things
that's gonna get looked at is
large-scale nutrient applications to
fairways and mediate rough and we've got
a lot of high-end golf like everywhere
else that's used to it'd be in a certain
way are you suggesting that a lot of
guys will just do that they'll they'll
they'll just put a granular out it might
make sense from a labor perspective I
know there's been studies even you've
done them right looking at urea versus
you max not not a huge difference how
much am I really getting by having more
slow-release in a in a fairway product
from a labor savings versus the nitrogen
that pulses the plants need it's also
generally a native soil out there not
saying yeah right more organic matter
you need less so in my experience around
here in Wisconsin people are applying
between one and maybe two pounds of
nitrogen per thousand square feet on
their fairways so what I would do if you
fall into that ballpark is go look at
how many times you spray a fairway and
divide your annual nitrogen rate by the
number of times you spray and if that
number comes down to a reasonable amount
of a quick release fertilizer like urea
then you can really inexpensively
fertilize your fairways by just adding
some nitrogen of the tank each time and
you can you can totally forego a
slow-release source and it also gives
you more control over when that stuff is
releasing not to say that granulars
don't make sense like you said from a
labor standpoint I see a lot of people
going down with the two-pound
application of a polymer coated urea and
we're done with it you know for the
whole year and that certainly is great
like I said it's just the the fairways
aren't as critical as the greens you
know you don't you know you know most
people aren't hand watering their
fairways and mapping the moisture in
your fairway so just think about exactly
like moisture put the amount of effort
in your greens same way you put your
moisture put the same amount of nitrogen
thawed and though how your
water in your fairways it's just more
room for air we're at the witching hour
call other questions yeah one more
question from Dave and this is some so
Dave Hicks superintendent the Cornell
University golf course that we worked it
with a little bit on this clipping
Boeing research and so actually one time
last year dave was doing a verdict
cutting and actually blew off all the
material and collected back and we found
that was a lot of material and was
almost you know in terms of volume worth
about a month of growth just from
knowing Doug do you have any comments on
if you've looked at vertical mowing or
core cultivation the other removal
methods of plant tissue and how that
factors into how much nitrogen you're
removing from the plant yeah and it you
know if you if you added up all that
stuff your soil organic matter and all
that you you got 20 pounds of nitrogen
in the soil right so if like if you just
let that stuff if you don't fertilize
you you can serve I have a long time as
that stuff slowly breaks down and that's
exactly it you're removing it because
there's too much there and you don't
want to replace that certainly because
so just think about the inputs the
outputs right you got too much stats you
want to remove that you want to get that
out of the system and it's all linked
it's all linked to nitrogen so you know
I'm not saying that you got to replace
everything you're you you remove it just
gets you to think about why you should
be doing it is because it is a balance
it's where did that stuff come from it
came from nitrogen being put down and
that's where it went and maybe that that
that's too much yeah do you want to
thank Doug and do the sponsors there's
another question so I didn't want to ask
another question Doug so we talked about
we're kind of focusing the conversation
on top growth and I know a lot of people
will ask me about well is when I make a
fertilizer application what if I'm using
primo and I'm getting more root growth
and shoot growth is that kind of a
one-to-one relationship whenever I apply
fertilizer I'm gonna get the same amount
of top growth versus the same amount of
bottom growth do I have to worry about
when I'm applying during the year is
that gonna differ
excited consideration people should
should have yeah I mean that's that's
you hear that a lot about like I'm doing
this for the roots right and it's like
that's that's what you say when you
don't want to listen to what I'm trying
to say no it's like the we're not we're
not doing anything in the roots they're
hard to measure they're hard for us to
quantify a course they matter but if
you're taking care of the top the
bottoms are gonna follow and we I don't
I've not seen what you're what you're
saying like a lot of big differences
that we're saying oh yeah it's showing
up in the roots but it's not showing up
in the top growth so I you know I can't
I can't really speak to your question
but that's my perspective on it well and
and and just to validate that a little
bit more you can see ten 15 year old
putting greens that dinelli had for
years the roots went down four inches in
stock if they were gonna keep growing
you know where do they go after they go
to the the bottom of the cup in the
first year Doug that mean they die back
and they sort of work in a particular
volume and they seem to not go much
deeper than that but they do create a
mass atop I'd like to take you down the
road of you know roots if you're
fertilizing for roots you could be
creating problems that you have to then
dilute yeah so and I'll put in a
shameless plug here join us at two
central for a green keeper discussion we
got rocku SWA coming up we're gonna talk
about organic matter but what I think
you should be doing is tracking your
organic matter by you know Michael Wood
says every two centimeters I say what
every inch what you know something
something like that go down where your
roots are you got four inches chop them
up into little bits and and and think
about that is that's where your nitrogen
is going and that's where your organic
matter is and and you again you manage
organic matter but your your sampling
methods are probably if you're doing
three or four inches that's not that's
not high enough resolution but yeah
growing roots builds organic matter and
that's something we're trying to to
minimize and so a plug for the green
keeper
one more time Doug yeah to 2 p.m.
Central
you can go greenkeeper app calm to find
the link and we'll have an hour
discussion with rock khuswaha
myself bill cruiser and and any
participants i want to join that sounds
like a blast
all right Doug thanks for joining us
Carl take us home
yep just one more time we wanted to
thank our sponsors for every one I did
with the GCS a a education code in the
chat box a while back so if you didn't
get that before we started you can go
look for that so again thanks to the
sponsors that are helped putting us on a
andre and some first gherkin or
ornamental Harold's
grassland our platinum sponsors our gold
sponsors Finch turf BASF MTE pump
irrigation tech remain our silver
sponsors Syngenta Ewing turf and soil
nutrient solutions Weber golf from turf
and dry jet be sure to tune in next week
and watch me try to tee it up for a golf
course architect with Ian Andrews that's
gonna be a sight to see that's right
next week's in session is Ian Andrew
he's gonna have some stuff on minimal
golf course design so that should be a
good time so with that everybody thanks
for joining today you can see us next
week same time same place for the third
week in our GCSE a a NY golf symposium
series thanks a lot see you guys thank
you all
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu